[Music]
the game I can't repeat the name is what
your head doesn't work and every single
change
Zippity help them feel justice wanna be
a patient hell the tricky yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo
it is Tuesday May something made
nineteenth happy birthday to anybody
that was born on this day I'm in a good
vibe I'm outside
trying to mix it up get that lighting
right for everybody out here just want
to give a big shout out kosher Dill's
always in the building my guy for a
decade at this point good to see you
behind the lens really appreciate you I
love the new intro as well can you play
one more time for the kids sure
[Music]
[Music]
huija positivity they're like positivity
like that [ __ ] in the end gets me going
how are you best good oh well yeah um
didn't get I woke up like every hour
last night but I'm too excited for tea
with Gary be the 15 minute earlier slot
like I think I was like anxious for you
I could I think I kept on thinking is do
I need to wake up right now like wake up
early yeah it was only 15 minutes guys I
know I'm crazy get into the show whoa
this is crazy
are you Wow um well first of all I just
want to say that um because my Instagram
got deleted at some point because I was
promoting my music and you were
mentioning take talk and when you
mentioned take talk I just went all in
and after posting 702 times my video
went viral with 15 million and that
literally started the process of
changing my life and I just want to
thank you for that that's amazing it
really means a lot so um thank you thank
you so to give a little bit of context
um what's your name tags well my my my
artist name is Jags and my name is
Thiago
real pleasure go ahead real pleasure so
um I was born in Ottawa Ottawa Canada
and I live my 9 years here and then I
moved to Belgium and in Belgium I live
nine years there and for me my passion
was really like dance so that was like
my thing and after that we moved back to
Venezuela because my dad's job was
finished in Venezuela lived six months
and really there I started you know like
I was I was by myself and I really had
to practice all myself you know and just
practice dance because I was very
entitled back in Belgium because I just
had everything right so I started
working working you know hard hard to be
hungry when you're fed exactly exactly
so I passed that time in Venezuela just
training dance and then from there the
was very difficult so we moved back to
to Ottawa Canada which I am now and
that's when I discovered music I was
like yo I didn't understand because a
lot of artists were more known and at
that time I was actually listening to ty
Lopez and when I came to your content at
first I was like way no this is too like
it was too agressive like a lot of
people say that it just starts
aggressive and after that I watched it
again and you were talking about music
and I would relate the music with my
dancing and then I would just listen and
listen and listen and really you were
like that only voice that really helped
me when everybody was just um like you
know telling me otherwise like oh you
got to do it this way you got to do it
this way but then I just kept you know I
kept listening you know I want to have a
part time job just you know cleaning
mopping the floor cleaning the toilet
just like hustling hustling humility
thank you thank you and after that yeah
I started posting my memes on Instagram
but the Community Guidelines they said
no we're gonna do your account like this
is not possible I was at 12,000
followers and then everything just
vanished and like I said you were the
same yo tick tock tick tock tick tock
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
take my chance when I'll take talk post
702 times trying everything and yeah
just tried everything and I was really
put I was really pushing the music I was
just dropping tracks and getting no
tracks in dropping tracks getting no
attractions and as soon as I had that
moment of tick tock I was like wow this
works so there was this mean going on
tick tock like a trending thing and I
use it and I incorporated it in my music
and as soon as I did that people loved
that the video on YouTube got a million
views it went viral and take talk and
after that I was like wow this works I'm
gonna continue doing cuz you you really
preach like keep doing what works and I
remember at that time I was this close
I'm not posting it but I just listened
to a video of you're saying be in the
yes business just do it so I was like
you know what I'm just gonna post it and
see what happens and that was literally
the process of changing
and then I did the same thing for I
don't know if you've heard my heart went
oops yep yeah well I did the same thing
with that one use the same sound I'll
take talk about I was like super happy I
was like yes and I did the same thing
with they call me Thiago it blew up on
sake talk and then another one just blew
up on sake talk and I just want to
really yeah and I just really wanna
thank you because you were really that
only voice that was helping me going
through this and the tik-tok game is
really real so thank you is there
anything I can help you with now yes yes
so I wanted to ask you um so I stayed
with the meet you see you say post music
consistently just drop music like
quantity versus quality and I've been
doing that for a while but now I'm
signing not a versus quality
you know that's the part that I think a
lot of people get a little bit confused
about my message I'm in the business of
quality and quantity quantity is not
subjective quality is you want to talk
yourself out of posting the post that
changed your life yeah because you were
judging the quality let the world judge
the quality you know so people people
think it's an or game and I think it's
an end game like to me it's it's not
it's not you know quality quantity over
quality its quantity is black and white
and quality is subjective of course and
so that's a big deal for me of course
and it's real it's super real it's how
the whole world's always worked and and
quality comes out of your ability period
whether you know if you've got it it's
gonna be quality you know some things
are gonna hit the market more you know I
say 48 things over and over I see them
500 to 70 thousand different ways and
eventually like one hits that person
right like maybe if I said be in the yes
business like that time thank God it hit
you and it worked but I say you know go
and do all the time it was just that you
know I remember that you know that
thought I mean I thought about something
the other day about like what's my
humanity footprint then thinking about
this term in my head like
like what's like humanity footprint
meaning like we talked about like our
carbon footprint and like all these
other footprints and I'm like yo what's
my humanity footprint like like what
what am i doing every day that's that's
making an impact on humanity here's you
know a kid from Venezuela Ottawa you
know you know you're up who you know
just listened it taught him the humility
to go and you know and mop floors it
gave him the courage and the ability to
put out seven hundred and two pieces of
content yeah and you know that's leaving
that's leaving a legacy you know so so
don't get it twisted my guy this is not
this is not you know quantity over
quality
this is quantity is black and white and
chocolatey is a hundred percent
subjective by the market not by you or
labels uncle or me Jack's yeah facts is
is is so true you know and I also wanted
to ask Ken content ever hurt a person
you know like let's say I drop tracks
but then there's one track that does not
do well can it hurt the artist or the
constant created the Beatles have bad
songs facts I see listen to it the other
day you know what I mean like I want to
say bad songs it means not popular you
know but like okay you know if it's
coming from your soul and you're writing
it or you're interpreting it or you're
composing it it's not bad it just might
not be popular sure no I don't think so
I think the only thing that you know I
don't I think the only thing that can
hurt someone
is when they come with bad intent okay
that's really true and all um so I was
very excited and what else should I be
doing as an artist you know like I
dropped in musics I'm also doing q and
A's you say a lot watch what I do
no watch what I say so I mean I see what
I probably do right now how many tick
tock followers yet I'm at one point nine
million I think you used the clout of
two
talk and you reach out to I would make a
list of the 50 to 500 favorite producers
or artists you have and I would DM them
on Instagram and say hey first you do
the homework
hey I've noticed that you haven't gotten
serious on tik-tok yet it's really pop
for me
why don't we collab on tic toc I can
give you a little a jump off point and I
actually think there's a lot of big
artists who want that sure so I think
what that does then is allows you to
actually collaborate and make a joint
song with [ __ ] future you know what's
[ __ ] you know jewel you know with
Aerosmith like I would just reach out to
like [ __ ] 50 to 100 dream people DM
them on Instagram and be like yo I'm
winning them on the talk you need to as
well you want to do something what I'm
gonna say yes sure that's a fact that's
a fact and my question is if in the
future after quarantine like if we could
you know maybe meet up and just chat
yeah you're open Thank You Stella scary
alright thank you all right we're Sarah
Dustin you [ __ ] threw me for a loop
that dude was [ __ ] epic she's next
everyone keeps yelling at me the right
finally hi man I'm really good how are
you I'm super well I'm so sorry for how
awful of a human being Dustin was
yesterday oh it's totally fine
I was totally [ __ ] my pants
yesterday to get on and so it gave me a
chance to settle it all myself down good
for today pleasure oh absolutely I'm
really good actually surprisingly this
entire experience being at home and not
physically being at my job it's actually
gotten me to a place where I'm better at
my job now it's exposed a lot of things
about people I think in general and in
in my case it's exposed that I'm good at
communicating through these types of
mediums especially writing not so much
video
I'm terrified of doing this right now so
I'm killing it at work which is
absolutely amazing but it I feel guilty
saying that because you know people are
obviously going through some really
serious stuff and I work in health care
so I see it every day but I'm on the
admin side so I kind of don't get that
direct contact but it can be
overwhelming it's stressful but
apparently those are the situations that
I thrive in and I didn't know that so I
learned that I'm proud of
um that's a really nice tree it's it's
good to learn those things about
yourself I think so I agree it's it's
why I want children to be in far more
diverse and and and adverse situations
yeah I have three kids and they are
awesome dads just run to school and
fight teachers and principals and
coaches and then [ __ ] fighting for
their kids and then their kids are 22
and they don't have a fight I completely
agree with you we have a kids special
education right now doing that and
they're thriving right now work like
doing school the way they're doing it
because they just don't have that
distraction they don't have that
negative energy that they might get in
school and they're kind of figuring it
out on their own and they're they're
doing great so I really really really I
also it's to your point it's so hard to
talk about the positives during home it
because of how much sadness is happening
but there are enormous amounts of
incredible things going on in the world
and and I hope people see them so I'm
glad you're here Sarah what can I answer
for you so I had two questions and
hopefully they're pretty short one's
kind of selfish and one's more about you
and general so I've been at the same
company for ten years right out of
college kind of fell into it but it grew
passion for health care helping people
I'm not direct health care it's not my
game I'm more on the admin side
operations projects all this stuff I'm a
sole contributor I don't manage people I
manage staying
and over that time I've really kind of
honed what I'm good at
and ever since starting to watch you
probably I think it's about four years
now
I want to say this self-awareness piece
was huge for me and I really spent a lot
of time focusing on that and I realized
what I'm good at what I'm not good at
and what I want what I don't want but
I'm worried that I know this but I'm
I've been at the same place for so long
that I'm potentially being pigeon-holed
somewhere that I don't necessarily want
to be well of course you're being
pigeon-holed everyone does and that's
okay that's just like a normal human
behavior right in structured
environments team environments working
by us yeah so I guess my question is is
there a way to kind of undo some of that
after you've been somewhere for so long
and if so what are your thoughts on that
it's just
Kandice conversation and communication
to the decision-makers it is literally
going up the ranks of like whoever has
leverage bosses partners you know bosses
bosses and just flat-out communicating
your truth yeah yeah yeah there's been
people in my career that I've
pigeon-holed that have come into my
office and said I'm this and I'm like
cool show me and some of them have
thrived and others have flopped and then
there's other you know people that have
come to other bosses and managers and
they yes them to death and never did
anything right and then the Sera's of
the world leave after another year
there's other people that have gone to
bosses and managers communicated it and
the person did nothing about it
and then the Sera's of the world Saten
dwelled about it and sat there for
another 15 years being pigeon-holed
that's what's cool about life you're in
control
you go and have the talk and then you
play the hand that's dealt to you after
they adjust to it one way or the other
yeah unfortunately for me I was two
weeks away from having that kind of
conversation
and now I'm no I actually I actually
think listening to your story lucky for
you that two weeks before you were gonna
have the conversation a global event
happen that even showed your skills even
more which probably is going to give you
even more leverage going into that
conversation I'm hoping that you're
right and I will definitely take that
into consideration I mean do you think
it's appropriate to approach this in
this situation like right now or do I
wait because I think it comes down to
the judge yeah you need to you need to
have a sense of who you're going to this
with right and I think it depends on her
or his demeanor you know it they're
enough I think timing matters I think
this could be an incredible time and I
think this could be an all time bad time
yeah you know I think there's I you know
I err err on the side of continue to
build leverage if you're shining so much
right now sure especially as we're you
know theoretically we're in some sort of
place that were gonna be out of this at
some point you know so I don't know I I
think there's still without knowing who
the judge of this is you know it's why I
love marketing to the world not to an
individual when you're at the mercy of a
human you're just gonna have you know a
very subjective kind of moment but you
know I think I think either way it's
gonna play out you know one way or
another like you know if you've got a
progressive open-minded empathetic you
know boss or leader or manager however
this is structured it probably plays out
well at any scenario sure if you've got
a little bit of a weaker insecure
political one then then I do think the
timing may play a factor yeah and I
think that's generally I'm a bit worried
about that I work for a very small
company I have a very empathetic boss
but the the power does not lie
necessarily with with her it lies above
her and so regardless of my conversation
with her it's going to be escalated so
it's really just you know I have to Kate
I have to pander to a number of people
not just one obvious yeah listen you
have all
those conversations yeah I think you're
mentally prepared to make a move
regardless so yeah I think that you know
I think you're in a win-win spot it's a
long time coming so I appreciate the
advice I have a second question for you
this is more about you so I'm hoping you
can answer so we kind of started the
conversation about you know how this
entire time is exposed you know
weaknesses strengths whatever some
people so what would you say it's
exposed about you and will it shape
anything you're gonna do in the future
that you wouldn't have thought you would
have done my biggest strengths thank you
my biggest strength is interpersonal
relationships and being in the same room
with somebody and feeling the energy on
some like goofy [ __ ]
that helps me navigate decision-making
the thing is exposed is that I can scale
that through video conferencing and that
blows my mind yeah and so it's gonna
change a ton of things I'm probably
gonna travel 25 to 40 percent less cuz I
don't need to go to Chicago for this
meeting where I have to feel it
all right it's going to allow me to not
stress about missing my kids things in
the middle of the day when I'm rushing
out the office to go to the thing now I
can leave two hours earlier and do video
conference at the Starbucks or the
apartment close by so it's a it's it's
you know - a lot of happiness for me
around around the balance of travel and
work the balance of non work events and
work events it's allowed me it's exposed
how advanced communication has gotten on
video conferencing platforms and and I'm
gonna take advantage of that I'm gonna
work from home probably once a week Wow
because I feel like I am it's exposed
that I concentrate more in my meetings
on video conference than I do in my
office so and then and then the thing I
you know I've had the luxury of
navigating my family business as a 20 as
a 20 as a 26 year old 25 year old
through 9/11 which we were very affected
by because we're in the heart of New
Jersey suburbs of New York City I've had
the luxury to navigate to businesses why
library and vaynermedia during the
economic crisis so the the exposure of
him am i a wartime general you know
that's what I'm that's why I've been
talking for last two or three years for
people to save their money and get
mentally ready like I'm I'm more
prepared for I'm much better at bad
times than good times yeah I like the
punch in the face
I like the adversity I like the fear I
like the unknown I like the challenges I
like the humility I like the step backs
I like the cancelling fun things to do
[ __ ] things so you know it hasn't
exposed it it's just reaffirmed
something I've already known about
myself great that's awesome to be here
thank so that's all I had so I
appreciate the time stay by good luck
bye thanks Owen let's keep this [ __ ]
going
Dustin Jesse what's Gary what's up hey
what's up man so a little background I'm
an 18 year old musician from
Massachusetts and I'm a senior just
graduated 2020 yeah and I empathize with
like my peers and stuff because they
lost all of their you know graduation
all that [ __ ] yep but for me it is uh
it's let me figure out something that
like like I'm finally free from the
constant comparison of like that school
had you know like I've always felt like
I was behind I was always not doing what
I needed to do but um now that that's
eliminated from my life I I know I want
to be a musician like it's it's I'm
going for I'm going for it like 100
percent good so my quick thing Jesse
first and foremost that comparison game
doesn't change just because you're out
of high school that comparison game is
in perpetuity you're about to compare
yourself to everybody who makes music
yeah and that's kind of what I was
saying but like um I feel like it's
easier because I know I want to do music
and I I care less about like it's
because I'm doing what I want to do
instead we don't have to do it kind of
being yeah instead of being compared to
like you know people who are getting
eight days and chemistry where I'm
sitting there
with a c-minus but I got an F in
chemistry so good [ __ ] okay thanks
so my question is this is like I've been
working on my debut stuff you know I got
the tick-tock roll and I got 22 or 21
thousand on tick-tock but I want to get
my like music debut but every time I'm
create and I'm getting discouraged
because it's not how I picture in my
head so my question is is like how do
you save yourself from that
discouragement before you release
something by realizing your opinion of
it actually doesn't matter what do you
mean by that
well we saw ty go right did you watch
the first interview yeah he almost
didn't post the thing that changed his
music career because he didn't like it
sure it's so [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] up
kind of point of view yeah like if you
think about it's like yo you're like yo
Gary I want to make this music into this
like I don't like it and I'm like well
you can't like your own [ __ ] or love it
because the market is actually gonna
play it out and that's [ __ ] up because
wait a minute like shouldn't I shouldn't
I have to feed it in it and where you
end up realizing it goes is like focus
on what you're saying more than your own
insecurities judging the output where I
want your mind is like did I tell the
world what I wanted to tell them not do
as my insecurities take over when I
listen to it do I hear it as a hit on my
subjective one person point of view
hmm you know I want one other thing is
like is it better to stay in one genre
and really build up that genre or try
multiple different genres different
genres because you're too young you
don't know if your reggae or hip-hop or
pop or country like if you even ask that
question the answer if one even debates
that they must try multiple genres sure
I'm just worried because a lot of
artists don't a lot of artists like I'm
hip-hop i'm country because they have
that conviction that's amazing
for you it's it's still a debate and you
need to go out and [ __ ] taste yeah
definitely thank you I it's just hard to
fight that like that fear cuz tick-tock
it's easy to post content I'm really
good about for now it's a cod yo for now
tick tock is gonna be hard for everybody
in two years Instagram was easy five
years ago to tik toks about to be hard
for everybody cuz everyone's gonna be
there it's not the platform it's the
judgment of the scale of the community
she talks easy cuz nobody gave a [ __ ]
cuz nobody thought anybody was there but
in three years
everyone's gonna struggle posting on tic
toc cuz everyone's gonna be there and
it's gonna [ __ ] everyone up just like it
[ __ ] them up on Instagram Instagram
just suck you up your insecurities [ __ ]
you up so you gotta kind of be ahead of
the game on like where it's gonna change
you need to be ahead of the game in your
[ __ ] head to not compare yourself
with any other human and give a [ __ ]
about what anybody you thinks then you
can go everywhere stay everywhere and
not give a [ __ ]
absolutely you understand yeah and it's
not about this is not about running away
from judgment this is about running into
judgment and getting cozy as [ __ ] with
judgment this is not giving a [ __ ] about
mrs. Harrington the [ __ ] chemistry
teacher or your best friend's mom who
thinks that their son is smarter than
you because they got an A and you got a
c-minus this is not giving a [ __ ] about
tick-tock at scale when everyone's on it
or how many Spotify listens or the a and
our god of your life or some [ __ ] or
your favorite [ __ ] artist [ __ ] on
your music when you DM them it's not
giving a [ __ ] about anybody this is
about giving a [ __ ] about one thing what
do you want to tell the world yeah I
want to tell the world bro that's what I
[ __ ] didn't know but like people and
the wine world hated me when I came out
with Wine Library TV social media was a
fad when I started doing business
content I would never make it because I
always cursed I was too old for
musically and tick tock five years ago
everybody's always told me no I [ __ ]
love no I want you to fall in love with
no follow up with two things brother and
your life will be amazing what do you
want to say and loving when people say
no you fall in love with those two
things bro everything gets good
everything gets good right now right now
you're right now your your the
ingredients you laid out for me are
there's a lot of opposite to trends
there what I love though is I don't feel
that you'll I feel like you're so young
so early and I feel like I think I think
you can pick up on this I think you can
rewatch this 5 10 15 times and really
build on it mmm it's about judgment bro
judgment all right thank you Gary I
really appreciate it does it make sense
just a little bit yeah here for a second
like basically basically let's stay here
for a second it's just about actually
not caring what other people think bro
it's literally the polar opposite of
high school bro I mean walk through high
school cuz I didn't give a [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I looked at peer pressure like
this like [ __ ] you want to give a [ __ ]
if the hottest girl thinks I'm a dork if
the coolest jock thinks I'm a dork [ __ ]
you show me where you're gonna be in
[ __ ] 30 years so that'll happen it's
bro yeah it's just hard cuz like for the
last 4 years you know you got so many
people telling you it like but so
instead of like feeling bad about like
people telling you that like you're not
gonna make it you're not gonna do well
you should learn it that should be fire
yeah I'm shoulders I love that I love
that you know you know there's no
there's Jesse there's no more delicious
flavor in the world for a competitor
than I told you so
sure yeah when you have the hit and you
make it the next key even though you've
created all that [ __ ] resentment is
to convert that into humility empathy
mm-hmm see I don't razz on my friends
and my parent and friends parents and
all the people in business along the way
that [ __ ] on me when I've made it I I'm
compassionate I see I'm nice to them
but I promise you their nose got me here
sweet awesome they know knows you're
good bro those are good those are great
bro knows our great nose or the [ __ ]
stones that build the house yes is but
yes is catch you off-guard
your mommy's saying that you're good
[ __ ] you up you believe it yeah that
that's actually one thing I've kind of
noticed is like I'd rather someone be
like brutally honest with me and tell me
like ah this song sucks then like oh you
but you have to make like well but let
me throw it out let me throw another
curveball you but then you have to not
believe that I loved when people said no
to me but I didn't believe them ah I see
yeah like correct and as a musician all
you have to do is did I tell the story
that I wanted to tell when when when
people said no to me even the [ __ ]
best Howard Schultz Cubans I was like
nah I'm better than I'm gonna be better
than you I'm gonna be better than you
man this is inspiring man I'm good yeah
so you see where it's coming from like
the know is good cuz ya ship on shoulder
but the key is to not believe them blues
a shitty part like like like like taking
the [ __ ] to build on and then convert it
it's like you have to be this like
machine you take in the now like okay
I'm gonna take this no I'm gonna split
the end the oh the end I'm gonna use as
a brick to like build my [ __ ] Empire
and the oh I'm gonna convert into like
I'm gonna circle it back at you'd be
like not [ __ ] you you don't know
absolutely so it's conviction and
humility and patience that adversity
build and build and build and then pop
up at 32 and have your moment true I
mean I'm all for I love the process I
love making music you know I'm I'm
prepared to live the kind of life that
it will take to succeed you know I'm
prepared to you know work in a
restaurant boss tables and yeah
is yes probably just Jesse but I'm
taking Isaac Jesse you gotta put a sec
no you gotta put out music no you're
you're that's the one thing of it
lacking of course cuz you're cuz you're
valuing their opinions too much you feel
like if it doesn't hit and if it [ __ ]
it doesn't do well that it hurts your
self-esteem I can't have you do that
that's why I jumped on the cut on the
high school thing I knew you were in
trouble off your first sentence not in
trouble let me let me rephrase I knew
there was opportunity to build here
because you're so young off your first
phrase comparisons increased post high
school hell yeah bro do you understand
what happens in four years when you
haven't made it yet everyone's gonna
make what are you gonna actually do with
your life now that this [ __ ] music
thing didn't work out that's what we're
going to say to you yes oh my that's all
my parents are saying to me too but I've
been trying to have that conversation
with them like you know this is what I
want to do I'm prepared to do this but
it's hard but I think I'll be able to
manage it I believe you alright thank
you so much Gary welcome talk to you
soon
he is a teen Wolf's productions alright
that was a good one Dustin there were
some gems in there yeah I really like
that one a lot
me too let's get the team to chop that
up and get it into the testing ASAP cool
let's get going
what's up Gary what's up coach Jay
always good man always good
appreciate you bringing me on right now
even though somewhere between yesterday
and today I lost my wallet and yeah I'm
freaking out but I said to myself you
know what
ABC adversity builds character
so did you leave my house yeah I went I
went somewhere yeah no I went to the
post office and it was closed because I
totally forgot yesterday was a holiday
here I'm in Toronto Canada and it was a
holiday and I got a drink I got some
snacks and between the post office which
is at the local drugstore and my house I
lost it it sold wait if you got some
drinks and snacks you paid for that yeah
so I don't know if I dropped it on the
way to back to the car or something who
knows I'll get off you're gonna go back
and check right yeah yeah I'll figure it
out then man
listen adversity builds character I be
listening for you for some kind some
time now you helped me through some
darkest moments I found you through even
Carmichael on his YouTube and you said
some powerful stuff there and I just
from that day on I just kept following I
kept following everybody that's been on
the show I kept following and just
asking them questions and it's
interesting because we're roughly the
same age I'm 43
I got two young two young girls and this
moment is a defining moment and like if
I get choked up it's because there are
kids like myself there are parents like
myself that don't know where to turn at
times and there are moments where you
have to write that goal down you got a
set steps in the right direction and
know that you're gonna you're gonna get
there you got to get a lot of nose like
you told that young man I got a lot of
nose because I'm an adult with ADHD and
I did not let that define me I'm not
letting that define my diet that's my
it's my moment coach Jay it's off
and the strength it is but it takes a
lot of you know you know the game in
between the noggin right like it takes a
lot of willing yourself to who want to
get to that next level and you know what
you have to do to get there so my
question to you would be Gary is I've
accomplished a lot of things in my life
because I took a lot of knows and you
know you said do tick tock do all these
platforms I literally told my Instagram
following which was a big and my
clientele that I'm starting this new new
initiative which is called gym class
with Coach Jets on on your your screen
there because the my the goal has to be
more important than the role John C
Maxwell said that that my goal in life
has to be more important than my role as
a person and I think that's what you're
doing it if there's kids out there that
think oh I'm never gonna get onto Gary B
this is a kid that took 20 plus years to
get onto Gary Vee right now
and I'm doing it honestly Gary I'm doing
it for them I'm doing it for all the
parents that don't know where to turn
when their kids are getting into trouble
or getting into it's drugs and stuff
like that because I'm on a mission Gary
with or without you Gary make sure your
push-ups today by the way I will time
every day
I promise yeah I tell Dustin every day
ask him I invested him every day say
make sure you do your workouts and my
message is to there are a lot of people
that are gonna be in coping and we're in
complete lockdown right now that don't
have an outlet and the gym is outlet
Gary I've been in by myself in this gym
no members nobody by myself for 10 weeks
and I've been doing things online and
trying to get the message out there my
question I wrote it down where do I take
my business that has no money into
something special that has mass impact
well it's just execution I mean like you
know you'll appreciate this like you
know it's it's step by step like first
you've gotta figure out how to monetize
so that you can be self efficient right
you know so that if you don't build a
foundation financially then
to do it in perpetuity it's gonna be
hard to have the kind of impact that I
think you've created in your mind and/or
you realize that impact doesn't need a
physical or financial execution impact
can actually be done for free on things
called the internet it's called social
network so it really depends on how you
wanted to find it you know I'm making
mass impact being garyvee and it's a not
a monetizable event for me I have my
other Garry Boehner took life where I
run my businesses and and I don't have
an institute I don't have an island I
don't have a course I don't have any
structure around it what I have is my
thoughts and my aspirations to leave a
you know a humanity footprint as I'm
calling it in my mind the last 24 hours
yeah yeah and that is and that is
happening on a on a daily basis across
every platform because I'm passionate
about leaving you know that impact more
so than you know taking that impact and
turning it into a monetizable event on
the flip side it's very okay to you know
turn it into a monetizable event suck
this is true sometimes I dream about
like you know what I'm gonna just buy a
[ __ ] Mountain somewhere and carve
into the [ __ ] mountain and be like
this Yoda character and like people just
gonna come then I'm just gonna chill in
there and do tea with Gary Vee [ __ ]
Mountain style and that's me my business
that's gonna actually I'm not gonna do
it for free it's gonna be business and
other times I think it's I'm gonna do it
for free what I'm saying why I'm telling
you that story because it's run through
my mind in that way is it's okay to turn
it into a business you just have to
realize are you in it for the impact or
you in it for the financial you know
ramifications or is it both all of it's
all good all of it's all good but take
it to answer your question coach Jay you
got to go on a step higher and say you
know if you want to make a global impact
like you said well then then you know
the reality is you don't need it to be
in the form of a financial success
execution you can just do it through the
words and your passion on the flip side
you you easily can I think the way you
do that is you start creating as much
brand as possible and create a virtual
ecosystem so it's not just Len
a Toronto Area you know both Mike the
Conte and Jordan sigh at both my
trainers have made significant money
training people virtually doing meal
plans and doing virtual workouts I you
know today at 6:30
I'll do a virtual work out with Mike I
like how you said doing your push-ups
today I cancelled this morning cuz I
felt a little a little like lethargic
which is rare yeah I knew was a leg day
Hey actually Sarah in our in our chat
group today was leg day - today's
shoulders so leg day is a beast so I
wanted to have more energy and have more
strength because those [ __ ] Bulgarian
split squats so so afternoon but
nonetheless brother I think it's I think
it's virtual virtual selling I think
that's I think that gives you scale okay
my last thing Gary and and and I really
appreciate you taking my call is that I
just want that message to go out to
anybody that is watching this that you
guys have to set goals because if I
didn't set that goal when I was 20 23 33
and now 43 this wouldn't be possible you
gotta set goals you got to believe in
yourself you got to take a lot apart the
second part the second with you it's
it's the belief when you you know people
set goals but they don't believe they're
gonna achieve them and then they become
jails I'm gonna be a famous singer but
they don't actually believe it and then
it becomes a convoluted code Shay a lot
of people have real bad relationships
with their goals because of the second
part it's about actually not only
believing in yourself it's actually like
a little tweak it's accepting yourself
yeah and it's not and and in accepting
yourself there's a key other component
don't put other people on pedestals you
know I watch all these young girls look
at like very pretty girls on Instagram
and put them on pedestals and and you
know everybody's got different bone
structure and different like like the
day we were all born different like
you're not gonna necessarily be able to
achieve certain things because of like
what God gave you and that but on the
flip side
you're [ __ ] you're you have the
potential be one of the great poets of
all time but because you want to be like
a hot one on [ __ ] on dick
talk you like suppress your actually
what you've been given because you put
somebody else on a pedestal because
you're actually insecure and you're
looking for validation from you know II
boys on tick-tock it's just [ __ ] up
right we need we need one you know
setting goals is imperative I love that
I'm with you but we need we need to we
need to build an entire generation of
self-esteem of self-esteem building of
acceptance like god there's so many
things I wish I was better at but I but
that was even a difficult sentence for
me to deploy because I've tuned out that
feeling since I was like [ __ ] 10
right all right
wishing means [ __ ] like so like yes
goals but let's have nice relationships
with goals which goes back to a bigger
perspective which is [ __ ] like
there's nobody on earth like you and if
you actually take that as a positive and
really try to figure out what the [ __ ]
you got real [ __ ] happens
100% you know notice notice how you and
I took a you know HD age and 80d ADHD
ADHD like like I just know it's a gift
but if your parents and your teachers
and doctors in society tell you it's a
stigma you become insecure 100% but if
you're told it's [ __ ] amazing look at
who's that supermodel who's got the skin
can it right you know you know I'm
talking about I'm not too sure so
there's a supermodel she's got a skin
condition where she's like you know you
know got like patches like you're like
you know super famous I'm just like I
don't pay attention that world but like
you know I know I know if I saw her like
she somebody just put her name again I
think I saw um you know like when Winnie
Harlow that's right so you know that
look could have been considered not
beautiful but she in her inner soul made
it beautiful
now the world thinks it's beautiful like
look at what look at what's considered
good-looking now when I was growing up
Kate Moss you know when I was a teenager
you got to look like Kate Moss to be hot
like that is an Apple look now no you
know it's
like you know things change but like
what doesn't change is you loving
yourself are you hating yourself and I
just [ __ ] want to I just want to get
everybody loved themselves period and
the story because the second they do
they start leaning into weird [ __ ] nerd
culture are you kidding me we're the
same age
right you were about to like comic books
and [ __ ] Pokemon and nerd [ __ ] now
the [ __ ] it's like a pop artists in
the world Rock [ __ ] Dragon Ball Z [ __ ]
like yeah didn't kidding me like Mickey
making millions off of it now make you
know right that's Gary man listen
there's a whole bunch of guests that
that need to hear their voice and I want
them to get their time I appreciate you
come to Toronto man hit me up for a
workout well brace they're following me
man so I got sugar like you send you
these workouts I went and and much love
to you man and all the kids out there
all the parents keep keep fighting the
good fight man gym class with coach Jay
I'm your guy and because I'm from Coach
K man peace out coach Jay all right guys
Gym Class Heroes I miss then coach Jay
you got the follow
I'm your hundred thirty first follow
watch s throw it back up throw it back
up Dustin let's do a follow storm
everybody in the vaynernation watching
tea with Gary Vee let's do a follow
storm
let's [ __ ] me I think we all can
agree that coach Jay is a sweet soul
let's just take one minute right now
even if you're watching me on a phone
you can step away for a second let's do
a massive follow storm let's do a follow
bomb whatever we're gonna call it you
know let's just blitz them let's just
split some let's split some ways up to
154 I expect to check this in a second
and I expect this to be at 700 let's
blow this guy away
let's make him super happy he's worth it
he's a good dude let's keep it going
hey yeah Gary hey thank you so much good
good thank you and thank you Thane and
Dustin in the background for doing all
of this also I do want to just say coach
Jay is the sweetest because he did he
followed everyone who's been in our
little private chat back here I went to
go follow him and he was already
following me so everyone should take
your advice but yes basically I'm an
actor that's my greatest skill that's
the main goal is to make that a
full-time thing for me but I to my own
surprise have found some success during
political comedy videos especially on
tick tock which thank you
100% because of you that I got on that
platform I did not expect for political
comedy well there but it's done it's I'm
everything will do well there Shea for
anybody watching right now who doesn't
think their thing works on tick tock
tick tock is a mass platform now
everything is on there it totally is and
I mean I see it with everyone that I've
become friends with through doing it and
how it's changed their lives it's it's
really it's my favourite platformer
which comes to my question because of
the success that I've had and also my
greatest skill is not writing I can I'm
a great actor but I've found that
political comedy helps me put a bubble
around it and focus as a writer so I can
create my own content so I felt as if
that's a good way into the industry for
me that I can wiggle my way in and make
acting a full-time job that way and it's
done well for me on tick tock and so it
also attracts fairly aggressive trolls
which I'm fine with except for and about
a month and a half ago I had one of them
report me one time on a live stream for
a dangerous behavior and I got my live
streaming band permanently which I
haven't been able to get ahold of anyone
at tik-tok to fix yeah some me an e-mail
I'll help you really oh my god yeah so I
started to the vaynermedia team who's
got relationships
with the performance see if they can
help I would so appreciate that cuz
that's that was my main thing as I was
really depending on it but would say you
need to be the mindset of if you lost
live stream on tick tock forever that
that's a minor event yeah well that's my
question
stick with me on this though yeah I
really want to spend a second on that
yeah like then just make tick tock
videos to send everybody to Instagram
like do you see what I mean I don't I
never want you to be at the mercy of the
platform yeah exactly and that's that
was my biggest fear is that I was really
depending on it a lot I've started
videos pushing people to to come to my
Instagram it's more of a fact of YouTube
Twitter yes you t open making where I am
on Twitter I'm on all the platforms
actually that more everywhere the amount
of time that it takes me to make a
political comedy video that I'm happy
with and that's relative I make a lot of
silly ones on tick tock just to post for
the day sometimes but the amount of time
it takes me I'm still I'm doing one a
day on tick tock I'm trying to figure
out how to basically diversify and grow
from here given that I assumed by a
lizard by eliminating your the part of
your sentence that says that I'm happy
on yeah yeah and just making an you
gotta make more yeah yeah no it's 100
percent what happens if somebody figures
out so for one tick tock right now as a
lot of people are winning in my
community because obviously it was an
early advocate and people are finally
starting to kind of like figure it out
the thing I fear is they're gonna have a
single tick tock that does well when
they're testing and then all their tick
tocks look like that because mhm
they're trying to recreate the viral
moment yeah when when you have something
hit you've got to do that but then you
got to keep constantly testing like it's
almost like you've got to make one one
one video that you like and you've got
to make one video for your old peril
Gary every day that's completely there
huh do you think that your answer if
your doctor as an actress you should be
making some
unique tik-tok that's not political
every time I think you're following
won't be upset if you have one that's
political and one that's just silly on
trend or one where you're acting
something that's happening yeah that was
my question is just do you think it can
grow past there doesn't need to kind of
niche down but grow yeah okay awesome
and I'm so excited I remember yesterday
you're trying to the filmmaker the kid
that was just out of film school that
you were gonna want to try and do films
down the road so I'm gonna keep em up
it's gonna happen one day so keep an eye
up yeah do it
thank you so much okay fight looks like
Coach J got lid on huh see I love this
community all right what's going on Gary
what's good fam how you doing well which
all my companies drew my name is Corrine
I'm waiting from I'm from Los Angeles I
just want to say how appreciative I am
for your consistent content man like
ever since I graduated college just just
kept me on the perfect balance between
motivated and grateful so I just wanna
thank you for that
um quick background basically I
graduated two years ago from UCI and
ever since I've had this topic on my
mind I've been really passionate about
and it's one you advocated a lot too so
I got myself to finally write a book on
it which is something I didn't want to
do for awhile and the topic is basically
on why you don't necessarily need
college to be successful depending on
where you're at and you know your
position in life and I just like touch
upon a lot of subjects that you go onto
you know what we don't need or it's not
the same thing because we have our
phones in our pocket all the time we
could just Google this information I
have an entire chapter that I like
dedicated basically to you I'm there for
your vacation so I was really hot to
talk to you about it and basically my
question to you today is I'm I just
finished writing it like a week or two
ago and I'm in the editing phase and I
want to see what you'd recommend in
terms of maximize my exposure when I
ready to release in terms of like
advertising social social media
word-of-mouth where you'd say to double
down on all that I would start putting
out as much content as possible on
tick-tock
for a day of the themes that are in the
book cuz that's a great audience for you
cuz it's young and it's the one platform
or you can catch virality right now as a
nobody on social media
now what type of like content would you
say just like me
like recording myself talking about my
ideas or yep okay I was I was definitely
ready for you to hit me with a tick-tock
because I know that's something I've
been wanting look if you're talking
about a book that says you don't need
college tick-tocks amazing cuz you've
got kids in there in that age group and
you've got parents now on there with
kids in that age group
okay it's your best platform you know
and what's funny about tea with Gary Vee
and tick tock is it's no different than
the askgaryvee show and instagram you
know into you know years ago when I was
doing the askgaryvee show a lot of the
answers were Instagram tea with Gary be
a lot of answers are tick tock it's
because attention arbitrage like you're
asking me how to market your book its
attention if I told you influencer
marketing and send everybody every
influencer of your book you're hoping
that they posted under Instagram and
it's tagged that's code if I told you to
do a podcast you hope the podcast as
well and people buy your book it's all
just one game the game is so simple it's
just attention and right now the
underpriced attention the opportunity to
garner his attention is tick tock it's
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] about six I can
[ __ ] tick tock disappear tomorrow I'd
give zero [ __ ] okay or [ __ ] less
have no investment and bike dance could
care less you know like not scared of
losing my 3.7 million followers on the
platform could give a [ __ ] but just make
the best of the words they're a hundred
percent got it
yeah anything else in terms are like no
weather so just double dutch that's the
biggest thing for a day or then of
course talk your thoughts talk about the
four year vacation but how are you gonna
make that video about the four your
vacation is it gonna be just you
straight talking in a mundane
or are you gonna take a song that's
trending and then do some sticker
overlays and then put a gift like you
got to be creative to the best of your
ability in that platform maybe you do
duets maybe you look for people talking
about college and you do duets like you
got a [ __ ] create and your ability
creating that platform contextually is
gonna be the variable in your success
Oh God yeah then I type of just going
through a different social media seeing
where I should like double down on
taking a fashion to like a little of
each or like going more on our one but I
will definitely take that advice and
start getting in on tick-tock and so on
see if you had any other like things I
could add to my book because I know
you're big honest nope
you know you've you've taken plenty of
thought starters from me right yeah
right what right where you're in belief
good is there any way you could take a
look at my book or something when it's
done I know you get it out but I love
you too I would you know listen I don't
want to [ __ ] you like books or my
kryptonite
yeah really talk about it I don't even
like my own 5 bestseller but I wish you
nothing but the best
I appreciate they gave me you're amazing
yeah you too bro all right Dustin good
show like that nice and solid came out
hard yeah 45 945 nice little timeslot
little early for some people some people
missed it yeah there's 15 coach Jay life
just got flipped upside down you know
he's happy as [ __ ] definitely big wine
text day debating between a white and a
rose a both under 20 bucks people been
yelling at me they need some under $20
wine so coming at that today if you
haven't signed up for wine text yet and
you buy wine on the internet or at all
you're you're terrible human you've
broken my heart and I don't like you
anymore also excite about my new Twitter
account Gary Vee TV Gary Vee TV I highly
I mean if a thousand people went just
followed coach Jay on Instagram I highly
recommend
you go to Twitter right now and follow
this account we're about to go super ham
on it if you want to know more about it
here is the four one one the people that
are gonna win over the next five to
seven years are gonna be very
comfortable and controlled the process
requires sacrifice all your actions have
to then map to backpack backpack
backpack nobody gives a [ __ ] about where
you grew up the whole game of scaling
the unscalable it's [ __ ] hard work
it's being respectful it's being a good
person to that that's just a good idea
it's there the flip things there
this helps right here there's $400 in it
I stay my lady like real [ __ ] tight
but you can't be crippled everybody here
judging themselves you're looking at
what's in front of you right now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up who the
[ __ ] you are whoever provides the most
value always you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
my only uncertainty or anybody like it's
just like try [ __ ] shut your business
down and go work for an apparel company
pretenders nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work so you
better get your speed up you better work
harder you better work smarter you can't
Google stuff you're not gonna be able to
do anything that I'm coming
TV like hell - check me out hope you
enjoy